j'avais hasting la même couleur
d'arroser série est tu l'a beaucoup de
manques et c'est pour ça qu'on a fait
tout ça pour toi
des bonbons piments défense à tout ça va
te plaît tu es gusta il n'assume a
tellement manqué une super élèves bon
voyage à chat
[Musique]
du mois faute au départ j'étais encore
celui de la réunion j'espère qu'il va te
plaire au revoir vu que tu vas me
manquer je t'ai fait approfondie avec
les régions
j'ai trouvé la rivière il est beau
challenge pour moi il est trop beau il a
manqué
benallou on a ça pour toi c'est avec
tout notre coeur et ça criait de plus
écrit un petit mot
bon bien sous toit bonjour à tous
inez la comedd cima à aulas voilà voilà
qui tiennent à ayutthaya mada des dalles
et mis en pratique de l'art inha ainsi
au la pop comme les stars mondiales
si tu est chaude et menace pas la vie
avec
[Musique]
s
les ennemis
[Musique]
mais
salut
puisque ça démarre vite héros c'est mon
deuxième est à 2,3 mds et la jeunesse
espagnole
oui bah si un grain ça vaut son prix des
machines des choses ici j'ai tout j'ai
l'esprit j'ai vécu longtemps dans cette
voie là cg le blé le meuble heureuse
qu'avec mans mais pourquoi tu achètes un
truc promis alors ok donc on se dit à
ses heures hockey la saison morte de
stringer a fini à 1 ça ne va boxer non
averti que l'autre alphonse 'pirates'
dans la politique celle plus tard
ok allez
qu'est-ce qu'on pouvait offrir à inès
bah je sais pas quand mais la dernière
fois qu'elle avait bien aimé
sinon je pense pas trop c'est à jouer
pour lui apprendre à tt tt qui
s'affairent prenez le comme toi et non
pas merci bon pourquoi pas peut pas ce
qu'on me les noix j'ai pas d'ordi
internet
badens j'ai une idée avait bien été des
trop bonnes confitures
c'est fragile c'est pas faux
et en plus à l'est la fin mars qu'elle
avait pas dit non non non moi je suis
sûr et va aimer tout enfant la bonne
personne avec un bon parfum comme ça
reste quand même fragile unité toi as
mais des photos de la réunion alors mais
ça c'est bon ça on est ici en plus et
robert paris d'amis qui se qualifie bon
c'est ça
sa toune voilà il a sonné par un petit
truc pour toi avec des potes
alors inès en pas d'âme quand j'étais
ici c'était tout en laiton miroir ou
alors tu étais avec ton sac comme sale
alors avec mon chewing gum
pour l'heure tout et tout le temps avec
eux tous ces buildings andré cheveux là
métier la vie ici tu sois pas relaté des
sceaux est récent
m
sinon il est est trompé quand je t'ai
envoyé le contrôle à dans la figure
ouais t'as perdu t'as s'abattait la
rivière tu te rappelles je te rappelle
aussi quand était parti chercher un
moment j'ai en tout cas ils ont
progressé six semaines il se souvient
quand on va manger la glace là tu te dis
que la glace était trop froid et tout ça
en fait jusqu'au l'intéressant comme on
dit des roquois à l'eau descend bien ce
n'est pas en contenir et il est rappelle
la dernière fois quand on a couru sous
la pluie
ah ouais c'est vrai la route et en même
temps lui de combler un complet à nos
services complets celle ci n'est qu'au
bien que c'est
[Applaudissements]
il se rappelle de la rivière
à quel titre
alors quoi
en fait l'honneur call qui voit ses
livres au maire qui vit au volcan et qui
des points non je vais tout simplement
qu'ils sont méchants
arrêtons aussi on va chez divia taxi a
failli amener avant tout quoi n'importe
quoi alors là
bas valais tout allait mieux vous
n'arriverez à la brique
voilà huit alors par contre nous
là bas revenus et pas tous à la pomme
après la bronca contre l'épidémie
au total à 12
et oui quand il ya des tuteurs un bon
rang mondial voire la flamme
ça me rappelle l'année dernière on avait
pris mois la belle était pétri regarde
c'est l'action ça
avec vous tous c'est la solution ça je
ne crois pas dit si c'était peut-être
d'avancer papa décide
moi j'ai mieux avec ce alors poursuivie
avec un peu près n'importe quoi pour non
non c'est une autre histoire mais alors
[Musique]